the construction business is no bed of
roses cutthroat competition makes it
hard to stay on top but one construction
and design firm has been making its mark
on some of our biggest landmarks
Sheryl McKissick Daniel now sits atop
the oldest african-american owned and
female run construction company in the
nation a business her family truly built
from the ground up in the male-dominated
world of construction everybody's worked
it and given a door Sheryl McKissack
Daniel feels right at home even in a
hardhat and he'll it looks like we have
a lot to do in a month as president of
McKissack and McKissack she manages
projects from a park in downtown
Brooklyn to getting many of New York's
trains to run on time this is actually a
new yard completely new completely new
her company is on board to revamp Long
Island's railroad hub the one running
underneath the home of the Brooklyn Nets
this is a subway in fact McKissack
Daniel's business is assigned to just
about every major infrastructure
improvement project financed by the city
and state including current construction
at LaGuardia and the new terminal one at
JFK what does it take to compete in the
big leagues
it takes relationships and getting
people to realize that you bring value
to the table something unique and
different
you know our difference sometimes is is
our best quantifier qualifier the
qualifier for the nation's oldest
african-american own female run
construction management firm we trace
our history back to 1790 dates back to a
Tennessee slave named Moses Moses
mckissick the first was taught the trade
of making bricks by his Scottish slave
master a trade passed down to her
grandfather and great-uncle who
incorporated the family business in 1905
they're the first black licensed
Architects in the country over the next
60 years they built homes hospitals and
colleges my grandfather built a Tuskegee
Air Force Base where black pilots
trained to desegregate World War two
in 1968 McKissick Daniel's father
William took over laying the foundation
for his three daughters we would go to
to work with him every Saturday starting
at 10 years old walking construction
sites tracing documents you know
learning about building systems early in
life and so that was all ingrained in us
when her father suffered a stroke in
1982 her mother Leatrice be McKissack a
housewife had to step in I don't know if
my husband was gonna live a day but the
next morning at 8 o'clock I had five
major architectural and engineering
companies calling me because the message
that I already got out that my husband
was seriously yeah the business was that
good yes they all wanted it they all
wanted with no training in architecture
the former schoolteacher used good sense
and her master's in psychology to find a
way they were saying you'll never make
it you're not an architect you're gonna
run the business into the ground that
day she found her courage the liquid
kind my husband had a bar in the
conference room so I said I'm going in
this bathroom I get 45 but just crazy
bored me and she said well I tell you
what I have a legacy and I have three
daughters and my daughters are gonna
take over this business Leatrice
McKissack actually grew the business
adding to its list of 50 million dollar
complex at Howard University and the
National Civil Rights Museum in Memphis
by 2000 McKissack Daniel took over the
helm and moved the headquarters from
Nashville to New York this is a
competitive City it is a competitive
City Frank Sinatra said if you can make
it here you can make it anywhere and
that was my theme song
I was so glad when jay-z did the remix
so that I could have you know a new
verse to add to it because that's what I
would tell myself but breaking into the
Big Apple she says was only made
possible by affirmative action before
that they weren't doing business with
women or minorities not really no but
here you are coming from a legacy of
business it doesn't matter because
people do business with people that look
like them all the work that we've done
outside of New York it didn't matter
in New York her work did matter to the
community she served beginning with her
own sixty-one percent of her hires are
minorities thirty-four percent women our
mission is beyond the bricks and mortar
our mission is to change the lives of
those communities in which we build with
projects like the three hundred and
twenty five million dollar patient
Pavilion at Harlem Hospital Center which
ensured employment to those who lived
there we had seven thousand seven
thousand applicants walking up to our
trailer looking for work she hired 200
and developed a job training workforce
program to try to place the rest in
other fields across the city who are you
telling this story to I am telling this
story to women of color that the
construction industry can build wealth
the construction industry can look like
them but it's not an easy sell even for
McKissack Daniels own family so who is
the sixth generation I have two
daughters my twin sister has one
daughter and my older sister has two
daughters not one is showing signs of
taking over the reins that's pressure
I may have to hold on for the grandkids
love her she's amazing but the legacy
does not end with her her twin sister
Daryl has a mckissick and McKissack
separate company in Washington DC she
does more federal contracts was so
interesting she did the Martin Luther
King she oversaw that the construction
an impressive family and I love that her
mom Leatrice McKissack that moment she
went to the bar but she got it done she
did